in this segment we will go through the
calculation of the variances of some
familiar random variables starting with
the simplest one that we know which is
the Bernoulli random variable so let's X
take values 0 or 1 and it takes a value
of 1 with probability P we have already
calculated the expected value of X and
we know that it is equal to P let us now
compute its variance one way of
proceeding is to use the definition and
then the expected value rule so if we
now apply the expected value rule we
need a summation over all possible
values of X there are two values X equal
to 1 or X equal to 0 the contribution
when X is equal to 1 is 1 minus the
expected value which is P squared and
the value of 1 is taken with probability
P there's another contribution to this
sum when little X is equal to 0 and that
contribution is going to be 0 minus P
all of this squared times the
probability of a 0 which is 1 minus P
and now we carry out some algebra we
expand the square here 1 minus 2p plus P
squared and after we multiply with this
factor of T of P we obtain P minus 2 P
squared plus P to the third power and
then from here we have a factor of P
squared times 1p squared minus x minus P
that gives us a minus P cube then we
notice that this term cancels out with
that term P squared minus 2p squared
leaves us with leaves us with P minus P
squared and we factor this as P times 1
minus P
an alternative calculation uses the
formula that we provided a little
earlier let's see how we how this will
go we have the following observation the
random variable x squared and the random
variable X they are one and the same
when X is zero x squared is also zero
when X is 1 x squared is also 1 so as
random variables these two random
variables are equal in the case where X
is a Bernoulli so what we have here is
just the expected value of X minus the
expected value of x squared to the
second power and this is P minus P
squared which is the same answer as we
got before P times 1 minus P and we see
that the calculations and the algebra
involved using this formula were a
little simpler than they were before now
the form of the variance of the
Bernoulli random variable has an
interesting dependence on P it's
instructive to plot it as a function of
P so this is a plot of the variance of
the Bernoulli as a function of P as P
ranges between 0 and 1 P times 1 minus P
is a parabola and it's a parabola that
is 0 when P is either 0 or 1 and it has
this particular shape and the peak of
this parabola occurs when P is equal to
1/2 in which case the variance is 1/4 in
some sense the variance is a measure of
the amount of uncertainty in a random
variable a measure of the amount of
randomness a coin is most random if it
is fair that is when P is equal to 1/2
and in this case the variance confirms
this intuition the variance
of a coin flip is biggest if that coin
is fair on the other hand in the extreme
cases were P equals 0 so the coin always
results in tails or if P equals to 1 so
that the coin always results in heads in
those cases we do not have any
randomness and the variance
correspondingly is equal to 0 let us now
calculate the variance of a uniform
random variable let us start with a
simple case where the range of the
uniform random variable starts at 0 and
extends up to some n so there is a total
of n plus 1 possible values each one of
them having the same probability 1 over
n plus 1 we calculate the variance using
the alternative formula and let us start
with the first term what is it we use
the expected value rule and we argue
that with probability 1 over n plus 1
the random variable x squared takes the
value 0 squared with the same
probability takes the value 1 squared
with the same probability it takes the
value 2 squared and so on all the way up
to N squared and then there's the next
term the expected value of the uniform
is the midpoint of the distribution by
symmetry so it's n over 2 and we take
the square of that now to make progress
here we need to evaluate this sum
fortunately this has been done by others
and it turns out to be equal to 1 over 6
and n times n plus 1 times 2n plus 1
this formula can be proved by induction
but we will just take it for granted
using this formula and after a little
bit of simple algebra and after we
simplify we obtain a final answer which
is of the
one over 12 and times n plus 2 how about
the variance of a more general uniform
random variable so suppose we have a
uniform random variable whose range is
from A to B how is this PMF related to
the one that we already studied first
let us assume that n is chosen so that
it is equal to B minus a so in that case
the difference between the last and the
first value of the random variable is
the same as the difference between the
last and the first possible value in
this PMF so both pmf's have the same
number of terms they have exactly the
same shape the only difference is that
the second PMF is shifted away from 0
and it starts at a instead of starting
at 0 now what does shifting a PMF
correspond to it essentially amounts to
taking a random variable let's say with
this PMF and adding a constant to that
random variable so if the original
random variable takes the value of 0 the
new random variable takes the value of a
if the original takes a value of 1 this
new random variable takes the value of a
plus 1 and so on
so this shifting PMF is the PMF
associated to a random variable equal to
the original random variable plus a
constant but we know that adding a
constant does not change the variance
therefore the variance of this PMF is
going to be the same as the variance of
the original PMF as long as we make the
correspondence that n is equal to B
minus a so doing this substitution in
the formula that we derived earlier we
obtain 1 over 12 B minus a times B minus
a plus 2